I visited an old Civil War Cemetery in a
little town called Higginsville Missouri
about 800 Civil War soldiers are at rest
here many of the gravestones are old and
weather with time there's a certain
amount of peace and Tranquility here you
really feel a deep Connection to the
Past a sort of timelessness pervades you
and right next to it there's a little
White Chapel built in
1892 by the women who lived in the area
for the cost of
$1,200 you have to love the workmanship
of these old buildings there's a unique
solid quality to them that time itself
seems to bring to life and while
standing inside the chapel I felt like I
was briefly at times transported back to
a much simpler time a time where things
were easy to understand things didn't
get overly complex back then there was a
right and there was a wrong and they
were simple to understand much easier to
understand than the Rights and Wrongs of
today but there's a particular element
in this Cemetery that really stuck out
and it lies way in the back of it one
simple Tombstone with the name William
quantril inscribed on it let's go there
now and I'll tell you more about it
there
are presumed to be about 800 civil
four Graves at this
site
and I'm going to show
you few of them let's walk through here
you can see some of
these Stones here with some of these
dates 1838
1926 uh
1918 so some of these
are pretty worn
[Music]
down 1839 and
1926 we worn
down there's
one John Burton
1846 to 1931 and he was actually part of
General Sterling Price's
regiment that fought at Wilson's
Creek it's very famous battle in
Missouri there's a battle of Wilson's
Creek and then there was a Battle of
Lexington and I'll tell you that I'll
tell you about that in a second
here Frederick Smith
1840 1936 Clark's
division Alpha Windsor 41 to
36 but here is one
one as some of you may know about
William quantro
Captain William quantro born in
1837 died the year the war ended in
1865 this guy had quite a history
now Captain quantro was
known to be a Gilla he was actually one
of the very few Confederate Guerilla
soldiers of the Civil War and what
happened was he was originally born in
Ohio and he moved down to
Texas and he met a guy I forget the
guy's name but he was a Cherokee
Warchief he learned uh Ambush style
Guerilla tactics from this Cherokee
Warchief now this was around 1860 1861
right at the beginning of the Civil War
so what quantrol did is he joined
General Sterling Price's Army in 1861
and he fought he actually fought
in uh the Battle of Wilson Creek and he
also fought in Lexington those were the
two battles two famous battles in
Missouri both of them the Confederate
side won now Missouri itself the state
for most of the war it was actually
under Union control but at the very
beginning of the war the the governor
was outwardly Union but he he actually
was uh privately a Confederate on the
Confederate side So eventually the Union
forces came in and pushed Sterling's
Army down to Arkansas now that whole
time William quantra was part of General
Sterling Price's Army and it was not
until late September of 1861 that
quantril decided hey you know what I'm
just going to go off on my own he he
left General Sterling price behind and
he started a
gorilla gang so to speak and they went
out and uh basically did their own thing
he was a confederate Guerilla leader and
they basically went out and did whatever
they wanted he did a lot of killing he
went out and did a lot of damage there's
a famous battle in Lawrence Kansas I
believe where he uh slaughtered around
150 soldiers and also I believe
civilians as well it was a pretty bloody
battle he had a a string of Victories
with his Guerilla gang he got the group
up to
450 people but eventually right around
the time when General Lee surrendered
quantril and his gang he was reduced
down to maybe 10 people and he was
outnumbered and they caught him and they
sent him I believe to a prison camp in
Louisville Kentucky where he died of uh
wounds in 1865 at the age of 27 so
somewhat of an interesting figure in
Civil War
history and again we're looking at
the the graveyard here that surrounds
him interestingly his gravestone is at
the very if you look at this right this
is the edge of the graveyard and this is
like way way way in the back this is
literally almost as far
back as you can get there's this
gravestone right there but you can see
that's the front of the graveyard and
that's the big Monument for some reason
they put him way at the
back of this graveyard I don't know if
there's any kind of meaning or symbolism
behind that it's called a Confederate
Cemetery but from what I found out um a
woman at the Museum down the road here
she said it's a mixture of Union and
Confederate soldiers this is just
outside of Higginsville Missouri it's
probably about 5 miles off of Interstate
70 and if you get a chance to come down
here it's it's quite phenomenal there's
a chapel right there I'm about to see if
I can go into that and check it out okay
we are inside the
chapel next to the
cemetery and it says here that it was
built in
1892 for
$1,200 the current stained glass window
replaced the original pre2 window
that's featured in this
picture
so
1892 and it
appears and there's a stained glass
window that is
mentioned not the original but it
appears that the majority of
this
is
authentic
really really an amazing job on the
ceiling hard to believe that this was
built for
$1,200 looks like we had the original
floors
very wellmaintained
we're standing outside the
chapel built in
1892 and this is a obviously a
historical
landmark
built in that same time period actually
just near the end of that stick Style
of architecture that we saw at the train
depot they still have that
cross-section of uh what they call stick
work and here you have a very very steep
as you can
see a very steep roof which is
uh and right there too you can see and
that base basically is your typical
stick style component where they have
the Steep roofs they had the overhanging
eaves there um they don't have the
projecting Bays on here
though you know that had quite simple
handiwork back then
but they put a lot of
effort into how they built their
structures they used very good Lumber
And Lumber was Lumber is probably one of
the most important distinguishing
characteristics
between
your late 19th century homes and
buildings and your modern buildings of
today they had just really good quality
Lumber coming from gigantic trees in the
forests uh they didn't cut any quarters
they put a lot of Pride into their
work um so they took their time on
building these structures and that's why
you see a lot of these still doing just
fine 100 to 150 years
later and again you see that that steep
roof there which is one of the uh
distinguishing characteristics of a
stick style architecture from that time
period And even that roof right there is
quite steep as
well head to the
angels all your dreams are
angless light that s is
cre SE
Within and I'll keep riding through the
storm and the rain and the
wind
ever again I be riding through the
streams and the hills and
wind
ever again i' be racing with the clouds
In The Heat Of The
Sun
ring on
[Music]
[Applause]
standing here a clear magic stream there
were birds that knew all and all were
singing one of them
star down from the trees it's said keep
going on with
your
Dre
your the